let's go back uh how did uh you
initially end up linking with cash money
like what what what was it that you were
doing that put you on birdman's radar
super random couldn't even plan it like
i did this feature for this kid uh
my homie noel kid famous at the time and
he was being managed by dj nasty who was
like
yep good dude did we talk about dj nasty
from orlando yep that's my brother and
uh nasty hit me up and was like yo i got
somebody that want to check you out and
[ __ ] birdman and so bird called me up
one day it was like basically just
because i did this feature record with
this kid he hadn't really heard nothing
of me and he was like man come to miami
i want you to play me some records and
then it was
just kind of on and popping from there
super random super random
birdman offers you a deal what year was
this 2013 [ __ ] yeah yeah 2013 yeah did
you even like look at the contract i
sent it off to the lawyer but i was like
yeah whatever it says let's go like
honestly like bird
like our relationship was different it
wasn't like
all businessy and late you know labels
like it was just him being like yo [ __ ]
i want to be a part of your career like
here's a bag
like honestly cash money's been like the
least like i don't know i was blessed
with that situation like they never were
like stricklers on trying to recoup
money from me and just weird [ __ ] like
to be real they just gave me a fat ass
bag and did some things for me so i'm
like well because we always hear
the bad things about birdman oh [ __ ]
cat or like you know my fans will be
like his music's changing because the
cash money and birds not putting off you
know all that kind of [ __ ] but like my
real perspective of it is that like you
know i don't think nobody owed me
anything in this world and so to me like
birds did far beyond what he owed me you
know he don't owe me [ __ ] so he gave me
you know 200 racks or something like
that when i was 19. you know i was legit
so that was super dope 200 bands yeah
and so like they did some other [ __ ]
like as the label for me video shoots
and a couple of things but after that it
was kind of like they were going through
the [ __ ] with wayne streaming music
became a thing so like the whole
situation just kind of changed and like
i think they were still like at this
place of like learning how to navigate
the new music scene because you know
it's not the mixtape era anymore it's
like you know this new era so i think
they're trying to figure that out and i
just kind of did my thing but they just
always gave me freedom to put out the
music i want make the music they never
tripped on you like recuperate or
nothing bro they let me put cash money
logos on merch and sell the merch and
keep all the money they bought me a tour
bus for a tour didn't recoup any money
off that like they [ __ ] ali mean bro so
all those like indie projects that
you've been putting out like that's all
you i have 100 of all of that money and
i always have what's your relationship
like with birdman because i know you
talked to him not too long ago yeah
we're talking [ __ ] like it's just good
like he's just kind of like a mentor do
you think like if you really catch a
wave he's going to call you and be like
hey man
yeah yeah and i'd probably rock the [ __ ]
out because to me like he just is
real solid like you know from whatever
people's perspective is on like what the
label could have done but i think people
have this like perception that like a
label could really make you pop in and i
i think there's more things the label
could have done maybe to be behind [ __ ]
but i'm like you know i think really the
burden falls on the artist and i wasn't
really ready to carry that burden at the
time so
you know i was just legit so